this is a Fox News Alert good evening
welcome to Washington I'm Bret Baier
tonight Democrats are trying to minimize
the self-inflicted damage from comments
viewed as anti-semitic by one of their
high-profile freshman lawmakers we're
also at this hour awaiting the
sentencing of former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort first the
Democrats and anti semitism what was
once thought to be an easy fix the
public resolution has turned into a
political football and Republicans and
even some Democrats are saying the
Democrat leadership in the House is
fumbling that football chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
starts us off tonight from Capitol Hill
with a vote that just wrapped up
Canadian Mike Bret good evening to you
the vote was 407 to 23 with Iowa Steve
King voting present but this has been an
epic struggle all week House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi forced to defend one of her
controversial and high-profile freshman
members it's up to her to explain but I
do not believe that she understood the
full weight of the words a reference to
Minnesota Democratic congresswoman Ilhan
Omar who suggested those who support
Israel have dual loyalty and that being
opposed to Prime Minister Netanyahu and
quote the occupation is not the same as
being anti-semitic the anti-semitic
resolution noted that the House of
Representatives condemns anti-semitic
acts and statements as hateful
expressions of intolerance that are
contradictory to the values that define
the people of the United States but
after an internal battle among Democrats
the name of the resolution was changed
to anti hate and was broadened to
include a wide range of bigotry victims
Jews Muslims Hindus Sikhs the LGBTQ
community immigrants and others with
verbal attacks incitement and violence
were savvy living at a time in this
country where we're seeing a rise in
anti-semitism arise in
Islamophobia arising racism and bigotry
rallying to omars defense some of our
fellow high profile freshmen New York
Democrat Alexandria Ocasio Cortez has
been tweeting her defensive Omar to
nearly three and a half million
followers there seems to be no problem
at all with his zero-tolerance stance
for simply asking about u.s. foreign
policy and Michigan Democrat Rasheeda
Talib went even further I can tell you
when she speaks about those issues what
I hear is her trying to uplift my
grandmother in Palestine in the West
Bank and saying that there are real
actual factual evidence to show that
there's human rights violations
Republicans sounded stunned by the civil
war on the other side of the aisle
there's a fracture obviously in the
Democrat Party there's a radical leftist
fringe that's really intolerant but
particularly towards our Jewish friends
and now some Democrats are upset
leadership caved and well one of our
colleagues invokes the classic
anti-semitic Trump's the anti-semitic
language the Jews control the world that
Jews care only about money that Jews
cannot be loyal Americans if they also
support Israel this too must be
condemned Republicans say the shift to
the left is shocking this is not your
father's Democratic Party if it was ever
more obvious and today I don't know when
it was more obvious they can't condemn
they can't agree to condemn
anti-semitism some sources suggest this
signals possible trouble for speaker
Pelosi and her leadership team over the
next two years when you consider this
non-binding resolution was really quite
a struggle this week right Mike Emanuel
live on the hill Mike thanks